in this capsule we will see the rule
of chaining and the opel rule then
start with the chaining rule that's
a rule that will be able to make the link
between a marginal probability and the
conditional probabilities
we will start with the rule of the product
that rule for the particular case
with two random variables so
according to this rule rise if we take
the example of spam that tells us that the
probability that for example spam
be equal to fo is unknown or equal to
fact can be written in two ways one
can write it as the probability
marginal of strangers would equal times the
probability that for there is legal wrong
knowing that unknown is true where we can
also write it as the priority
of legal power fake times the
probability that a stranger is equal
Le Havre knowing that for yelle is equal
wrongly and generally whatever
the value of spam was
unknown so as you see if I have
not specified the value one has whatever
their value of the variables
random all the time that in our
case here policy spam and unknown
and with a strong image of the probity of
spam and a stranger this is the
politics of strangers times politics
unknown sacha spam or it's also
our ways of calculating his probity of
junk times the probity of strangers
knowing the value of spam and we
can take this rule of the product and
generalize it to the corner a barbie name
lags in n2 random variable that I
going noted x1 up excels in that
if the joint probability of x1 up
to ixelles well we can what we can
to do it's separate but two groups of
random way in group two
extremes up to x men -1 then xn
only
and if I mention the rule of the product but
it's going to say it's the product of the
joined probability so marginal on
only ex years up to excellent less
1 times the probability of xn knowing ex1
up to excellent - this is 2 of
way the cures if I can replicate
product stops but on this
probability here here about my values ​​and
thouars ex1 until excellent - a game
not separate the two bodies the two
group ii x up to excess -2 and excel
- and if I apply the stop of the product
so that here range of the ex years up
great way it's the product of
enjoy the screen up to xl less
twice the probability of an excellent
- hours knowing the values ​​of the ex
until excellent - 2 and then I
still my term here and if I continue
like that I can get the formula
general which is the probability of x1
until ex n is equal to the product of the
probability of xy knowing the variables
random x1 until aix i - 1
and that I do the product for there is
equals 1 to reindeer
so that office is a way of
to express it if the product of everything but
not ultimate marginal hexis purchases them
variables etc without up to aix and less
young people and in my notation I can
assume that the coc equals a calf
corresponds to only the producer
marginal of the ex a name that will have no
continue because also and this symbol has
here if you wonder what it is
it's the equivalent of the summation but
or rather than accumulate right now
the terms here we will welcome them in
multiplying them together so that's
a way to write probability of x1
times the probability of x2 sacha experts
times the likelihood of peace then the
part ii x3 sacha x2 and x1 is instituted
up to the probability of hicks and
sasha x1 to xn - that's the rule
chaining
the chaining rule it's true
whatever the distribution
his spouse on everything but variables etc
101 up to rexel on what it wants
to say it's actually rather than
specify but joint probability and
who are up to excellent a bit like
I did at the very beginning hall in the
first capsule where I gave the
priority of assigning my three
random variables for all
possible causes for the specified call
my conditional probabilities of x1
sorry my door is marginal from the ex in
pretending to be my own which conditioned ii
x2 sacha ex1 my probity continue from
the ex 3 knowing x1 x2 and so on
for everything but random variable and if
we give everything happened and the water
here I can calculate with the stop of
chaining all its producers
here so this is an equivalent way of
define a probabilistic model up but
random variable for example in my
spamming neck but I so I
only
I therefore consider even simpler
with two random variables for y
go unknown rather than specify
all the probabilities attached for
yelle is unknown I could specify
the marginal policy says long on
spam so what is probity has
priori to observe to receive a
email because if we ask that 80%
of time I get a bridge for yen
then but to find out that
I get that I get are some
spam and then we say that I
could define all my priorities
conditional possible so the quality
that the sender is unknown when I
get paul when I'm scared it's a
email so the priority in that
if they happen to have been thrown it's up to
to say that if I know the shipper no
sorry if I get
I received spam the chances that I
do not know the sender
the sounds are not good if I get a
kind be not spam so if I
received one I received a valid email
the probability that I know
the sender therefore unknown on galas
fake and pretty high then we notice
if not, ie if I
know that I received it is beautiful and
well spam in that if the
probability that I know
the sender ie the address
of the sender is not unknown is
lower is much higher so
I do not know the sender what
so in that it does not represent too much
badly a Korean and so so at the beach
had specified all that I could
calculated all but not ultimate marginal
on email and so unknown between
others the probability that for yesterday is
false etc. unknown be true it would be the
probability that a stranger is true
knowing that to go in so must in
this case also this probability the man
is given but give here it's zero
point is the unknown productivity is
true knowing that to go there must times
the probability a priori that spam
is fake gala and it gives me here
so I produce it from 0.1 says 0.8 it's me
gives 0.08 and so that would be according to that
model parity e-mail attachments
equal fake and unknown there is the true
and then another example if I would do
not but that you can do like
exercise
ok but let's imagine that I did all
these definitions of marginal probity then
conditional but that there I want
calculate the probability that the emails
that I received from tax be what a
spam knowing that I observed that
the sender's address is unknown
ok so noticed that here is the
conditional in the opposite direction me
I had defined in my example the
probability of unknown knowing spam
but I'm asked and I'm interested in
calculate the spam policy
knowing unknown so if that's
actually it would allow me to
make a decision whether to observe
that the sender is unknown
I put the email in a box
emails or not ok but it turns out
that I can still do this calculation
even though I defined p2i sacha known
sacha for yesterday i'm able to
calculate
and then knowing spam and I
do it as dense as if I have
actually need the probability of
unknown knowing spam but also from
the probability of spam only
so actually the probity of
spam equal fake knowing that a
unknown by definition would equal
conditional it's the probability of
spam equals false and unknown he
should divide by the probability of a
unknown and wasted this priority on
these two labs there I can
write it as because of the rule of
chaining like the unknown policy
gallerey knowing junk there is the fake
times to go there fake galls I
again this is the same theme
who says if I find him here and my
unknown marginal probability equals true
it's the marginal probability is known
would equal for illegal it takes more the
parity is known and gavray could
legal should so I sum up on
murderous laboratory bullets
spam since is not specified
is another way to see that this is a
way for me to normalize in fact my
numerator who are at a knock if I
put all the numbers
I do all the calculations I will do them
no time but it gives me 0.08 of
0.08 more
it's at the water point which gives me 0.4
so even if I had defined
colter of unknown knowing spam and
to take advantage of the careers I am able
to laugh at Der derivatives derived actually
the spam policy knowing
unknown from the part of that
then the rule of beille is a rule
who will formalize this reasoning the
basic rule says that the probability of
some causes sacha options that
we observe can be calculated as
being the product of the probity of
effects sacha the causes times the pole t & d
causes the word of marginal causes
standardized so dividing by the
marginal policy effects in
our body the basic rule that actually
the link between my spam policy
knowing that I observed unknown that I
know the value of unknowns and says that
it's actually the production of strangers
knowing spam times my probability of
standardized spam by dividing by the
marginal parity of unknowns in the
context the bank of decline we will say
that the quality of spam or the
probability of cause it's a
probability
a priori what does that actually mean
that's what it's all about
it's our belief about the fact
a new email is spam
even before we have seen its content
and we're going to get with obese stopping
a posterior probability so that's
the probability of sacha spam
unknown and this makes it our belief
which has been updated
after observing that the author of
email and is unknown or not so in
this case if these unknown galas true
would we could update it is
what our certainty about the fact
that our mail received an email to
using his business proofs that
corresponds to finally calculating a
probability to posterior of the rule of
base makes it possible to smooth 2 probability
the assembly will allow us to do
finally
probabilistic reasoning the other
way to finally see the abc rule she
will allow us to get a
probability diagnosis none
probability that makes it possible to do the
diagnosis of causes from
some observed effects and therefore hyper
do it from that she that from
of a causa probability ie a
probability of a distribution of
effects from the ribs
is needed though
also we define the
prior probability of the accounts the
part of his little used the rule of
basis and reasoning
probabilistic